en marzo de 2012 siria se hunde en la
guerra varias fábricas francesas deciden
poner fin a sus operaciones pero no la
farsa que busca mantener su producción
en la fábrica deja la villa consciente
del peligro la cementera francesa toma
la iniciativa establece contacto con
varios grupos armados que operan en la
región entre ellos el grupo estado
islámico a cambio de la libre
circulación de su personal y de su
material la justicia francesa sospecha
que lafarge entregó cerca de 13 millones
de euros a los yihadistas y sus
intermediarios entre 2013 y 2014
revelado en 2016 por unos periodistas la
noticia se convierte en escándalo en
septiembre el ministerio francés de
economía interpone una queja y abre una
encuesta preliminar dos meses después
dos ongs ponen otra queja en junio de
2017 la fiscalía de parís abre una
investigación el motivo
sospechas de financiación de terrorismo
en siria
primero investigan a ocho ejecutivos y
dirigentes y un año después es el turno
del grupo lafarge de estar bajo la lupa
complicidad de crímenes contra la
humanidad financiación de organización
terrorista poner en peligro vidas ajenas
y violación de un embargo el grupo y
tres directivos apelan
en noviembre de 2019 la justicia anula
la complicidad de crímenes contra la
humanidad pero mantiene los demás cargos
una decisión ahora revertida